[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
grandissent indéniable il y a d'autres
gens qui remplissent des stades et
d'autres pays mais même chez nous donc
c'est clair qu'il y a il se passe
quelque chose vraiment
la salle c'était incroyable que tous
vous voir est-ce que vous pouvez nous
refaire un petit peu les bracelets verts
un petit peu ce soir
vous la France on a un taux d'engagement
qui est incroyable c'est-à-dire que nos
fans nos spectateurs les gens qui
regardent le truc sont hyper à fond et
on les voit dans les événements
internationaux dès qu'il y a un Français
ça gueule de partout tu vois ils foutent
le bordel c'est un truc qu'on aime bien
[Applaudissements]
adapté
la grève comme ça
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je m'appelle Paul arrivé je suis
journaliste spécialiste de l'esport à
l'équipe depuis plusieurs années
maintenant l'esport c'est quoi c'est les
compétitions de jeux vidéo c'est un
monde qui est très jeune qui en
développement qui est assez excitant car
ses propres codes ses propres
compétitions ses propres stars et moi
mon rôle c'est de le faire le faire
découvrir
[Musique]
raflo c'est un très jeune joueur de
Super Smash Bros ultimate Super Smash
Bros ultimate qu'est-ce que c'est c'est
un jeu de combat un peu particulier
assez cartoon où on peut voir Mario et
Pikachu s'affronter raflo il a 16 ans
donc il est très jeune et ce qui est
intéressant avec lui c'est qu'il fait
déjà partie des meilleurs joueurs
français de de Smash alors qu'il a
commencé la compétition il y a pas si
longtemps que ça
qui va être intéressant de savoir avec
raflo cette saison c'est est-ce qu'il a
les épaules déjà pour rester parmi les
meilleurs joueurs français et surtout
est-ce qu'il a les épaules pour faire
partie des meilleurs joueurs du monde de
Smash
pour moi c'est il a le potentiel pour
devenir l'un des meilleurs joueurs du
monde si ce n'est le meilleur joueur du
monde si il continue de travailler pour
un petit garçon de 15 ans quand je l'ai
connu il était très terre à terre il me
disait la première chose qu'il m'a dit
c'est moi je veux pas arrêter l'école je
veux devenir ingénieur je veux pas
arrêter l'école je veux continuer les
études je veux je veux pouvoir nourrir
ma famille plus tard de pouvoir aider ma
maman etc et tout mes parents ils
viennent de Turquie on est d'origine
kurdes
en France donc on est venu ils sont
venus en France
quand ils avaient 16 ans 17 ans ils
étaient relativement jeune ils avaient
plus ou moins mon âge et ils sont venus
vérifie ils ont travaillé ils ont pas eu
forcément la chance de pouvoir étudier
forcément vu qu'ils connaissent pas la
langue et du coup bah nous on est né ici
dans 93 depuis tout petit en fait
[Musique]
en fait il va que pour obligatoire c'est
pour il faut avoir sa boursement 30
secondes c'est un très bon élève il
avait 17 de moyenne au collège quand
même et de 17 de moyenne et même
actuellement il a des très bonnes
moyennes en lycée ouais c'était un bon
élève malgré le fait qu'il était dans
dans le jeu vidéo qui voulait qui jouait
mais je sais pas comment il faisait pour
faire pouvoir faire les deux en même
temps en fait il aime beaucoup les jeux
de combat
donc il aime les Dragon Ball Fighter Z
il aimait aussi Smash Bros il me parlait
tout le temps de ça et puis quand il y a
eu le trailer on va dire la
bande-annonce de Smash Bros ultimate et
ben là il est devenu fou il a commencé
il est devenu fou et il pète un câble
juste il attendait la sortie de ce jeu
donc on a commencé à jouer ensemble sur
Smash Bros et j'étais très nul
et il m'est explosé sur les gens enfin
j'étais vraiment j'étais pas son level
j'ai vu que sur discord il participait à
des tournois il m'expliquait il
participait à des à des petits tournois
et bah c'est à ce moment-là que il a
vraiment commencé à devenir un joueur
pro
et là le tournoi il se déroule à
l'espace culturel de Drancy du coup dans
la ville la ville que j'apprécie
beaucoup et en plus ça en fait quand
j'étais en primaire en CP je crois
j'avais fait un spectacle exactement au
même endroit où je joue sur scène
maintenant ça fait bizarre c'est en fait
c'est un cours de circonstances tu c'est
impossible de prévoir ça tu peux pas te
dire ouais bah en disant je vais devoir
pro et je vais revenir là et je vais
jouer ça sera moins regarder je serai
pas je suis en train de faire des
maracas à côté dans un spectacle tu vois
c'est pas pareil
[Musique]
bah nous on ne fait plus tôt pauvre de
base niveau loyer tout ça le frigo ouais
c'est compliqué mais du coup il gagne il
gagne pas mal Denis pour payer les
courses par exemple il a déjà aidé
pour pour des fois les factures je pense
beaucoup moins mais quand même quand il
y a des petits imprévus tout ça
et ouais il aide ça va il est généreux
c'est quelqu'un qui est hyper
responsable qui a eu beaucoup de
responsabilités assez tôt et voilà je
pense que sa vie elle doit pas être
facile mais il assume surmonter ça et
bon heureusement il a trouvé ce match
[Musique]
mon rêve mon objectif d'être le meilleur
joueur du monde et en même temps d'avoir
terminé mes études tranquillement ça
serait vraiment le comble et en même
temps de pouvoir me développer à côté
sur les réseaux
de quelqu'un de bien aussi dans la vie
de tous les jours puisque c'est beau
d'avoir des meilleurs joueurs du monde
mais c'était pas c'est pas c'était pas
un bon être humain aussi c'est à ça
compte pas donc un bon être humain
terminé mes études tranquillement avoir
un diplôme et être meilleur joueur du
monde ce serait
[Musique]
coucou c'est l'un des meilleurs joueurs
français de League of Legends il a été
champion de France et puis il a décidé
de partir jouer aux États-Unis il a eu
cette opportunité il l'a saisi parce que
c'est une des rares Ligue qui te permet
de qualifier pour les championnats du
monde de League of Legends et puis c'est
ça le rêve de toukouilles comme tout
autre joueur de League of Legends c'est
de disputer les Worlds et évidemment les
gagner
[Musique]
gros enjeu pour tout cuit quand il part
aux États-Unis c'est de savoir si il a
le niveau en fait pour jouer
dans l'élite américaine il sort du
championnat de France il va jouer dans
une des plus grosses ligues
internationales et ce qui va y arriver
je me suis je me suis un peu renseigné
sur ce qui était la ville forcément j'ai
vu qu'il y avait du soleil et je me suis
renseigné aussi j'ai contacté quelques
Français qui étaient venus ici pour leur
carrière en eSport d'ailleurs j'ai une
histoire c'était que quand j'étais en
terminale et que j'avais mes profs qui
me disaient ouais attention devient pas
pour gamer tu vas t'enfermer dans ton
jeu mais au contraire j'ai l'impression
que depuis que je suis pour gamer je
peux voyager énormément je peux voir
plein de nouvelles choses et ma vie est
plus
équilibrée je trouve au contraire
par rapport à ce que j'étais avant
d'être pro gamer qui est Gaiman dans sa
chambre disait par jour et voilà
5 du coup je suis loin de ma famille et
forcément il manque un peu et on est
vraiment loin pour le coup il y a
différents horaires aussi donc même pour
s'appeler et tout c'est un peu compliqué
mais
j'ai jamais vraiment eu peur de faire le
grand saut parce que ça fait ça fait
deux trois ans que dans ma tête dans ma
tête je faisais un grand saut que ce
soit à Berlin pour jouer en Europe ou
ici pour jouer en Amérique dans ma tête
c'était déjà préparé donc j'ai
l'opportunité j'ai pas trop réfléchi je
me suis dit bah on y va
[Musique]
indéniablement l'un des meilleurs
joueurs de l'équipe il reçoit beaucoup
de demandes c'est passionnant de le
regarder jouer c'est très excitant
d'avoir recruté l'un des meilleurs
joueurs français au sein de la LCS vous
savez il vient d'une région qui a déjà
une place dans la ligue mais je pense
qu'il est l'un des grands noms à venir
et donc son histoire suicide beaucoup
dans Google ce qui fait de lui un joueur
passionnant dans la ligue
du coup quand il part aux États-Unis
du milieu de tableau et en fait qui
compte beaucoup sur lui pour essayer de
passer un cap la question qu'on se pose
à ce moment-là c'est est-ce que fly
Quest et tout cool vont réussir à passer
Skype ensemble
donc là c'est là où on est
[Musique]
dans deux coachs
mais là il manque 3 jours vu qu'on a des
soucis de covid donc on n'est pas
beaucoup
dans 10 ans que j'aimerais avoir gagné
les Worlds donc les championnats
mondiaux même si c'est vachement
compliqué mais j'aimerais le faire et je
me battre pour le faire
2021 j'ai compris qu'il y avait une
différence de coaching entre les
entraîneurs européens et nord-américains
les attentes étaient différentes sur le
plan culturel et donc avec Alex notre
coach nous avons décidé de faire entrer
une certaine influence européenne dans
l'équipe pour la rendre plus performante
[Musique]
c'était une décision plus ou moins
mutuelle dans l'équipe
à des compétitions en Europe
j'ai entraîné des équipes qui jouaient
contre Loïc et qui participait
systématiquement à des compétitions
contre son équipe il m'a toujours
impressionné dans le bon sens du terme
c'est un beau garçon il y a beaucoup de
gentillesse chez lui c'est un cœur pur
c'est ce que nous aimons beaucoup chez
lui passer de la LFL à une région
majeure que ce soit la LCS ou la LC
représente un gros défi pour lui il y a
beaucoup d'ajustements à faire mais ils
s'en sort très bien il grandit
[Musique]
Rocket League c'est un jeu de foot en
réalité ou les joueurs ont été remplacés
par des voitures télécommandées l'un des
meilleurs joueurs au monde aujourd'hui
et français ça peut levatira il a 16 ans
il vient des Hauts de France et bah
c'est un crack va tira il rejoint la
Carine corp pour le début de la saison
2022 2023 c'est un peu un rêve pour lui
parce que il apprécie beaucoup cette
équipe qui est extrêmement populaire en
France avec beaucoup de fans circuit de
vatira c'est pour être champion du monde
dès 2023 donc on se demande est-ce que
elakacorps ensemble vont réussir à
atteindre cet objectif
alors on va à la holoca de la cave pour
justement tourner notre annonce et
prendre des photos en gros si ce qui va
se passer
[Musique]
le grand 70
la vie est dure
[Musique]
c'est juste incroyable
qui se réalise déjà sur certains jeux
quand j'y joue mon nom il y avait déjà
marqué cassé devant parce que justement
c'est mon équipe de coeur je regardais
déjà leur match sur d'autres jeux et
tout j'ai toujours aimé c'est un jour
très très jeune les joueurs sont souvent
très forts donc il y a beaucoup de
joueurs de 15 saisons limite quand on
est vers la vingtaine on est déjà vieux
par rapport à la moyenne des joueurs
quoi mais c'est vrai que vatira c'est un
très très grand joueur pour son âge il a
déjà vraiment prouvé beaucoup de choses
et avoir pu le recruter et avoir la
chance d'entraîner c'est vraiment je
suis très content d'avoir ça entre même
quoi moi j'ai donné l'idée générale
c'est je mange du poulet et je suis
plein de jeux
et on met de l'eau sur mes yeux pour
faire en mode je pleure devant ce poulet
pour reproduire le même
je pense il faut que je vous chope une
winds
pourquoi tu pleures il est si bon que ça
se foutait
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la vidéo va faire plusieurs centaines de
milliers de vues et en fait on fait ce
genre de vidéo ce genre de contenu parce
que nous on a une grosse communauté
derrière le club donc il faut qu'ils
apprennent à connaître les nouveaux
arrivants qu'on les fasse rire qu'on les
fasse découvrir un peu plus les joueurs
qui arrivent leurs personnalité etc et
quand tu crées ce lien avec la
communauté derrière bah la communauté
elle te le rend et elle va les soutenir
jusqu'au bout peu importe ce qui se
passe dans la compétition
[Musique]
c'est un ancien joueur professionnel de
fortnite c'est un garçon qui a fait une
préparation militaire et puis il a saisi
l'opportunité d'avoir une place dans
dans ce milieu sur cette scène
professionnelle parce qu'il faisait
partie des meilleurs joueurs français il
a arrêté assez tôt à 20 ans 21 ans la
scène professionnelle l'a un peu épuisé
il en avait marre donc il a décidé de
stopper sa carrière de joueurs
professionnels de fortnite très jeune il
est resté chez vitality il est devenu
ambassadeur du club est-ce qu'il va
réussir sa reconversion dans l'espoir
tout en se créant un peu ce rôle sur
mesure pour lui
[Musique]
c'est la rue de ouf
c'était quoi
[Musique]
voilà le lycée
genre là je me posais ici j'attendais
genre
j'attendais le lycée qui l'ouvre
et même quand il ouvrait
quand je me souviens que j'étais moyen
heureux d'aller ici vu qu'en gros
c'était le lycée de base moi j'étais au
collège et tout après je passe au lycée
comme tout le monde et j'ai vu plein de
mes potes comment ça va partir à toucher
à la drogue à comment ça a fumer tout ça
et tout ça change des gens du coup j'ai
un peu mal vécu tout ça vu que moi ça
m'a jamais intéressé tout ça et tout et
encore plus tard vu que bah je voulais
partir dans l'armée bah
interdits on déteste tout ça pour voir
si tu as touché à ça donc du coup j'ai
l'impression de perdre mon temps et
c'est vrai qu'il allait terminale quand
je finissais je finissais les
entraînements à une heure deux heures du
matin qu'il fallait se lever à 6h que
toute la journée je bossais et qu'après
à peine je rentrais j'enchaînais sur six
sept heures de d'entraînement plus le
week-end avec l'armée
en vrai ça va j'arrivais à tenir mais je
délaissé plus l'école qu'autre chose
donc forcément bah moi je travaillais
moi j'avais des bonnes notes moi j'avais
des bonnes notes moi ça m'intéressait et
moi ça m'intéressait moi j'avais envie
d'y aller et ainsi de suite ça fait un
peu un cercle
[Musique]
un cercle vicieux et du coup
terminale fortnite est sorti j'ai
commencé à y jouer et puis j'ai joué
plus j'ai vu que j'étais fort et j'ai vu
qu'il y a des compétitions dedans et
tout j'avais déjà entendu parler de
sport de machin dans des reportages
Counter-Strike de 2000 2012 des trucs
vraiment anciens de fou avec kenny's
tout ça et tout et j'étais en mode pour
il y a des mecs qui vivent de ça c'est
incroyable et en fait quand ça m'est
tombé un peu dessus j'étais en mode
j'attends quoi c'est c'est maintenant
faut y aller quoi il y a pas de
il y a pas ralentir comme on dit
c'est l'endroit où je passais où je
passais ma vie avant
ça change de temps
quand il commence fortnite il parle
jamais de devenir professionnel ni quoi
que ce soit c'est moi de temps en temps
qui voit des boucs comme sur d'autres
jeux puis je me dis tiens peut-être
qu'il y a quelque chose
et donc il va assez là il fait ceci il
fait cela ça prend plusieurs en plus de
place pour lui mais on s'en rend compte
mais sans s'en rendre compte et en fait
on le sent mieux l'histoire c'est qu'il
doit passer son bac on va aller
clairement comment ça se passe c'est
qu'il y a trois mois avant de passer le
bac et là il commence à avoir des
équipes ça commence à être plus sérieux
clim après je crois que c'est Bastille
Legacy où il commence
on lui propose d'aller à des boucs il
fait deux trois Lannes et puis un jour
je crois que c'est au mois de mars ou
mais un soir on se retrouver à 11h dans
la cuisine et puis papa je peux pas
continuer l'école je peux pas faire les
deux bon je voyais mon fils heureux
quand il allait à la préparation
militaire je le voyais heureux quand il
jouait quand il partait en Lasne et dès
qu'il allait à l'école c'était il était
fermé il parlait plus il est plus fin
enfin je voyais qu'il y avait un
mal-être quelque chose qui n'allait pas
et en tant que parents enfin en tant que
maman tout ce qu'on veut c'est c'est que
nos enfants s'épanouissent et sois
heureux je n'ai pas voulu aller contre
lui je l'ai considéré comme un joueur de
football je sais pas où on allait tu lui
dis bah écoute demain je passe voir à
l'école et tu arrêtes tout
[Musique]
merci
continue ce que vous faites sur YouTube
[Musique]
c'est l'une des figures de l'espoir
Français c'est quelqu'un qui a qui est
multi talent fait beaucoup de choses
dans l'histoire mais c'est surtout fait
connaître en étant présentatrice et
intervieweuse lors c'est aussi l'une des
finalement l'une des rares figures
féminines de l'esport parce que c'est
vrai que c'est une discipline qui est
censée être mixte mais au sein de
laquelle on voit assez peu de femmes
alors c'est quelqu'un qui crée toujours
plein de choses la question c'est de
savoir est-ce qu'elle va avoir de
nouvelles opportunités cette saison
[Musique]
aujourd'hui c'est les LFL retelda donc
c'est une journée de compétition
française de League of Legends à la
scène musicale à Boulogne et va y avoir
3500 personnes je crois qu'ils viennent
en garder aujourd'hui donc on se prépare
pour le shop
[Applaudissements]
il y a beaucoup d'événements en slime
avec le collier de la pandémie etc c'est
vrai qu'on avait un peu arrêté et là
depuis l'an dernier ça commence à
reprendre doucement donc on est toujours
très content de pouvoir voir les équipes
sur scène voir les fans voir le public
contente que ça reprenne
[Musique]
pour l'instant ça va le maquillage
coiffure c'est le moment où je me
détends un petit peu mais ouais la
pression va monter 30 minutes avant le
chaud je pense quand je vais voir la
salle qui va se remplir comme à chaque
fois
il y a mes collègues qui sont en train
de réviser
[Musique]
un petit peu on regarde quand même ouais
c'est quand même beaucoup de League of
Legends même quand même quand on est pas
en live moi je fais les interviews des
joueurs après les matchs donc le match
se finit eux font une partie et commente
une partie font les débriefs et moi je
suis sur scène à recueillir les
impressions des joueurs après la
victoire ou des fêtes mais ça sera
victoire plutôt
[Applaudissements]
c'est gentil ça va très bien vous êtes
content d'être ici pour le temps il y a
une lumière si tu veux
partir plus intensément dans le préchaud
de cette grande journée je vais
directement envoyer la parole à la reine
de l'isport qui nous fait l'honneur
d'être présent avec nous ce soir ce
qu'on a entendu gugus
[Applaudissements]
te
merci
merci beaucoup bonjour
la même chose à chaque fois je viens de
passer sur scène du coup je vais
regarder le replay à tout de suite pour
pouvoir si ça rend bien pour voir si
c'était correct ce que j'ai dit et j'ai
toujours été un peu comme ça je j'ai du
mal à être assez satisfaite de ce que je
fais même quand on me dit que c'est très
très bien je veux toujours essayer de
viser plus haut et ça passe par des
petits détails comme ça de posture c'est
que le début de la soirée le dernier
match de la journée qui est censé être
le match de la semaine avec les deux
gros groupes de d'ultra qu'on a vraiment
en espérance ça va ça va envoyer dans
tous les sens voilà j'ai hyper hâte et
bien mes
[Applaudissements]
dames
[Musique]